hallo herzlich willkommen in meinem
torten welt wie ihr schon andere
überschrift sehen könnt gibt es heute
kein rezept sondern ein gewinnspiel
ich hatte euch besprochen dass ich wenn
ich's 10.000 abonnenten erreicht habt
mal ein gewinnspiel machen möchte wo ich
einfach dafür zu danken
als ich dann beweglich jedem einzelnen
abonnenten dafür dass ihr mit kanal
abonniert habt und das habe ich meine
videos anschaut
ich danke auch denen die ebene
zahlreiche kommentare schreiben und
bewerten und möchte einfach mal etwas
zurückgeben und euch heute eine kleine
ein kleines gewinnspiel bieten
ich möchte mich ganz herzlich bei carus
zucker körper bedanken die das
gewinnspielen mit ein paar produkten
gesponsert hat was genau zeige ich euch
gleich im anschluss und ich möchte mich
auch bei allen bedanken die sicheren
onlineshop mit tattoos die haben mich
nämlich selber angestiegen und haben
einen gutschein im wert von 30 euro
gesponsert und hostess jetzt heute zu
gewinnen gibt es heute gleich zuerst
vielleicht noch wie ihr an dem
gewinnspiel teilnehmen könnt also
teilnehmen kann jeder der in deutschland
wohnt und ich fände insgesamt vier
gewinner auslosen
und zwar richtig so ihr schreibt einfach
unter dieses video bei youtube einen
kommentar und kommt somit in einen
lostopf ich weiß als altmodisch machen
schreibt eure youtube namen raus und
dann kommen die anderen ausdruck und
meine tochter wird
nämlich dann die namen ziehen und damit
auch gerecht wird und ich auch an meine
facebook fans erreichen mache ich so
dass auch die bei facebook angemeldet
sind
einen kommentar unter dieses video
schreiben können als ich werde dieses
video dann bei facebook posten
und dann könnt ihr eben da unter diesen
post einen kommentar hinterlassen und
können so eben auch in den lostopf
kommen und wenn ich dieses video teilt
bei facebook dann könnt ihr erneut ihnen
los zu bekommen das heißt wer eine
youtube erkannt hat und einen
facebook-account kann insgesamt drei mal
teilnehmen
ganz einfach fast umgefallen so wie ich
einfach ermöglichen dass jeder der meine
videos anschaut eben auch teilnehmen
kann und ich kann es jetzt halt auch nur
für alle innerhalb von deutschland
machen ich weiß dass ich auch zuschauer
aus österreich oder aus der schweiz
das werde ich vielleicht in zukunft mit
aufgreifen dass ihr da eben auch
mitmachen könnt weil er auch gern meine
videos schaut aber jetzt eigentlich erst
einmal was ich für euch vorbereitet habe
und muss zu gewinnen gibt natürlich gibt
es sachen rund ums thema machen und das
erste paket ist dieses hier
der gewinner bekommt einen passenden
farbe in christmas fällt vom superflat
einen gutschein von carlos zu verzaubern
und eine packung sondern das ist der
masse gino tropical und es sich
eigentlich so der beste von dem
eigentlich bekommen kann weil man den
auch bei warmen temperaturen und
verarbeiten kann
ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert weil
sie mir jetzt aber auch mal bestellen
also laut bewertungen soll das hier
wirklich der beste freundin zahlen denn
sie überhaupt gibt
dies machen wurde
gesponsert von carlos zu verzaubern hier
seht ihr auch ihren namen und du
bekommst auch noch dieses süße stoff
tüte mit dazu dient auch vollen caro
gesponsert wurde das hier ist päckchen
nummer zwei hier habe ich auch von
carlos superstar zwei assen farben
einmal in gelb und einmal in grün
vielen dank dafür der rest ist von mir
ich habe hier einen aus vorschlag für
euch mit dem können wir von dort aus
rollen oder auch blüten passte da hat er
kleine abstandshalter mit dabei da könnt
ihr gab den von land oder die blüten
passte in der richtigen stärke ausrollen
und auch sehr gleichmäßig du bekommst
noch zwei farben von wilden einmal lila
und einmal ein remis also dieser
elfenbein tun dann die zitrus presse auf
die alle so stehen die von gold ist hier
in häppchen auch mit daran kann man ganz
gut online gestellt bei amazon oder ebay
ist auch ziemlich günstig und du
bekommst dieses basismodell ihr set das
ist auch das was ich habe also mehr
braucht man im prinzip gar nicht gerade
als anfänger und einsteiger
das ist action nummer zwei und päckchen
nur zwei erhält auch noch diesen
kleineren zwischen aufkleber dass es so
einer in herzform und da steht hier
nochmal carus zauber drauf was diesen
kleinen dekoration und dieses hier ist
das dritte bäckchen du bekommst zwei
masten farben in schwarz einmal in
schwarz und einmal in pink von wilken
die gleiche citrus presse wir auf dem
zweiten paket waren das modellieren von
steht
und hier noch gerbera ausstecher also
blumen aussteller mit dem was über bruno
modellieren kann von kam aus der zauber
gesprochen hat und du bekommst logistics
die hier sind angebrochen dass ich meine
du bekommst natürlich eine volle packung
mit 50 logistics die hab ich bei
tagesziel gestellt in den niederlanden
und das wäre dann so das dritte paket
und das dritte paket ist an mir gesagt
der gutschein für die wandtattoos im
wert von 30 euro bei facetime führen
alle teilnehmen die einen twitter
account haben oder eben einen facebook
account
wichtig ist natürlich auch dass sie
überhaupt abonnent meiner minister kaum
zeit und auch auf gefällt mir gedrückt
hat bei facebook
so ist es einfach pfeffer energie eben
meine kann abonniert habe und regelmäßig
reinschauen und ich werde dieses
gewinnspiel jetzt sechs tage laufen
lassen
das genaue datum steht da oben in der
überschrift bis zu dem zeitpunkt werde
ich eben alle kommentare sammeln werden
mich dann an dem tag hinsetzen alle
namen raus schreiben auf zettel
schreiben in einen topf werfen oder in
der küchenmaschine keine ahnung
und dann wird eben meine tochter wie
gesagt auch diese zähne ziehen und 44
gewinnen
ermittelt ich zeige euch jetzt auf jeden
fall die daumen dass ihr gewinnt es
können leider nur vier leute gewinnen
ich werde dann auch mal schauen ob ich
vielleicht keine ahnung bei 40.000 oder
50.000 online gewinnspiel mach ich werde
jedem päckchen auf jeden fall was
persönliches von mir mit einfügen etwas
gebackenes ich schaue einfach mal was
sich bei den temperaturen geben roth
verschicken werft und berichtete neben
weiter auflösung zeigen wenn ich das
nächste woche das gewinnspiel auflöse
hier wünscht ihr euch bis dahin eine
schöne zeit es wird vorher natürlich
noch mal ein rezept video von mir kommen
und deswegen schon ganz bald wieder dann
bis zum nächsten mal tschüss